[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Shake Shack in midtown Manhattan
I'm joined by Mark Rosati the culinary
director of one of the most revered
fast-food establishments in New York
City possibly even the world and today
we're going to get an exclusive look a
sneak peek of the Nashville style hot
chicken sandwich it is not an ad it is
an exclusive first look sneak peek it
will debut nationally on August 1st and
also because first we feast is always
looking out with the crossover recipes
we're going to show you how you can
mimic this recipe at home we'll get into
making the fried chicken sandwich here
in just a second but there are a lot of
Shake Shack obsessives so since I have
somebody from Shake Shack I have some
burning questions
the off menu yes what's the most popular
secret menu item you know we have one
that's become like almost like a
legendary and our company it's called
the peanut butter bacon burger we did
that for just one day and one Shake
Shack many years back and about 40
people ordered it and they were tweeting
about it and telling all the friends so
well let's do it the next week the next
week we sold 400 we've never done it
again since then and but we have those
ingredients you come to Shake Shack to
kind of the menu actor order a plain
hamburger with bacon and ask for a side
of peanut butter sauce so you go to your
table I can sit down pour that peanut
butter sauce on there
and enjoy yourself so that's where the
world battle the first we feast
difference right there what's your
favorite Shake Shack menu hack one of my
favorites is a BLT because I love our
bacon it brings back all those childhood
memories but just so much better and
juicier and flavorful a few years ago
you guys took crinkle fries off the menu
and there was like an open revolt and
that's not going far what was that like
was it chaos at jicama it was such a big
change in what Shake Shack was all about
with our fries we serve crinkle cuts for
the longest time our frozen and for a
while we thought we can do better you
know work with the burgers fresh back
there we're making custard fresh daily
and every single shake
why don't we do a fresh fries but no one
really was happy about ya the critics
say one thing the people the people
could speak a lot louder a lot more
passionately at the end of the day those
are the people we're trying to make
hatch that November we actually posted
on Instagram photo the critical cut
fries and all we wrote was coming back
that he gave the date which is like a
few weeks later it was the most liked
post on Instagram that year you know
it's gotten very popular for people to
try to recreate their favorite chain
restaurant dishes at home and yeah Shake
Shack now you guys have a cook what we
do yeah so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to prep all the
different elements for the hot chicken
sandwich because the last thing we ever
want to wait for is anything else when
the chicken comes out piping hot
everything should be ready to go so what
we have here is some cabbage dice sliced
really thinly here and what we're going
to do is add to it a few different
ingredients here I have our herb butter
milk Mayo so we're going to add that
into or we're going to make a nice
little slaw here with this you also have
some hot sauce here too because if it's
a hot [ __ ] example yeah we're going to
put some on a chicken why not in here
too
what style hot sauce we actually use
needs a nebran mark it's one of our
favorite there's just something about
that flavor profile believe you maybe
tried so many we have a little bit of
salt and pepper then the last thing
we're to add in here a little bell honey
yep yeah exactly
if someone's going to make this at home
can you give them any tips can you walk
them through it at all especially when
it comes to the fried chicken because
that shutter that people mess up often
what we found is very key is making sure
the chicken is cut on the inner side so
that way it's going to cook as fast as
the crust gets nice and crispy and brown
so for us that's usually out 1/2 an inch
or maybe a little under again if you
want a lot of chicken cut it bigger but
just make sure it's nice and thin and
then what we like to do and this recipes
in our new cookbook is we marinate the
chicken ahead of time in buttermilk
which helps tenderize it helps add in
more flavor to it
so then when we go to dredge that and
flour and then fry it the chicken itself
is a lot more interesting has a lot more
nuance when it comes to frying it we
like to fry our chicken around 350 to
375 degrees
well the slaw looks great I feel like
we're getting closer and closer to
finally eating some sandwiches
all right absolutely let's build this
all right ma'am all right we're fresh
out of the fryer we have the chicken we
do not want to fumble at the goal line
no you're not so first thing I wanna do
is this chicken is how the fryer I have
our spikes here I'm going to start
hitting it with this here and what's
really key about this moment here is you
want to be hot out of kar-wai like a
little bit that oil still glistening on
top so as you shake it it's going to
start to hydrate or dry out mix here
what we like to do gears I mean if
you're doing a hot chicken Cayenne it
rules the roost but we also add a few
other different ingredient to again
create boughs to create peaks and leaves
in the flavor a little bit of guajillo
pepper in there so that with the Cayenne
to mother grant that's kind of our
vision but again there's so many great
puppies out there get them all try a
little bit of each find out which one's
your favorite are to try balancing those
flavors to top up your own like
seasoning plant now I think it's time to
build this here we have our chicken
shell in here here's my life Cheers
uh-huh so on a spice level I think that
this law really helps to cut it so then
what you end up doing is having a
and--which that lights up your mouth
sort of after you bite through this
delicious buttermilk chicken yep and
there is nothing better at 9 a.m.
am i right than a Nashville style hot
chicken sandwich is my new go-to
breakfast ah there you have it now you
know where to get the Nashville style
hot chicken sandwich it's available
nationally August 1st you want to go
with the app you can get it the 28th a
couple days early yep and now you know
how to make it at home as well it's like
you're right here with me and Mark
eating hot chick
[Music]
you
[Music]